on le sent pas vraiment parce que il y a
toujours de la concurrence c'est vrai
c'est pas comme nous ici voilà non mais
c'est vrai qu'on sait dans l'aventure il
y a des favorites et après enfin c'est
s'amuser à en profit du moment où on ne
pense pas vraiment à tout ça parce que
je sais que vous parlez entre Miss
France elle a pas qui t'ont dit ouais je
suis sûr que ça va être toi c'est sûr
il y a juste la miss Martinique
avant tout elle m'a dit je parle à la
Miss France
mais elle était trop gentille Bernard
Montiel avait dit que ça allait être toi
qui Emmanuel Macron serait président
Emmanuel avait dit également qu'il
allait faire une grande carrière parfois
il dit des trucs vrais parfois il dit
des conneries
Alexis est-ce que est-ce que toi c'était
ta favori dis là tu peux le dire
maintenant une de tes favoris
de devoir de réserve elle faisait partie
des favorites oh merci quand même il y
avait aussi Nord-Pas-de-Calais j'avais
beaucoup de tendresse pour midi
alors dans le milieu des Miss midi c'est
Midi-Pyrénées
elle était super
Martinique était hyper mignonne
d'ailleurs c'est de toutes les nuits
c'est la seule qui m'a envoyé un petit
message par mail hyper bien écrit en me
disant voilà je vous remercie pour cette
aventure c'était merveilleux la vérité
j'ai une question pour Alexia je suis
pas non non mais là c'est Miss France si
tu peux c'est une dire à la star
donc je fais très vite sinon tu me dis à
moi d'abord ah pardon c'était l'année où
à la base ils devaient ouvrir aux mamans
au tatouage aux femmes qui sont un peu
plus fortes enfin tu vois l'année un
petit peu à tous pour montrer que la
beauté c'est pas de 36 à mettre 80 là
cette année quand tu regardais toutes
les filles je n'ai jamais vu ça de ma
vie c'était que des mannequins que des
bonbons encore plus que les autres
années alors ils sont où les trans les
mamans celle qu'on est gros cul tout ça
alors Alexia Alexia Alexia
[Applaudissements]
question de Mathieu Delormeau
tu as raison on a parfaitement ouvert et
maintenant tu peux être maman tu peux
être marié tu peux te présenter il
s'avère que comme tu le sais c'est pas
nous qui choisissons les gens qui se
présentent à nous au niveau national
c'est au niveau local donc au niveau
local il y a beaucoup de en l'occurrence
tu sais que andrea est arrivé assez loin
et puis après il y a une femme aussi qui
était mariée en Alsace etc mère de
famille après c'est le choix du public
localement donc nous on ouvre
plein de fois j'avais été sélectionné tu
vois donc voilà donc c'est pas de leur
faute voilà je te le dis alors Indira
vous avez 18 ans vous êtes étudiante en
licence de communication et vous
souhaitez travailler dans le design
spécialisé dans la communication
publicitaire visuelle déjà j'ai rien
compris vous voulez faire quoi en fait
c'est simple je vais faire directrice
artistique d'accord tout simplement en
gros c'est la communication spécialisée
dans le design donc tout ce qui est
création de flyers packaging
et donc terminale quoi terminer il y a
plus vraiment de filières c'est plus des
spécialités pour moi c'était sciences
économique et sociales histoire du
sciences politiques
qu'est-ce que tu t'es dit on va revoir
la séquence de tout à l'heure quand tu
tailles ton nom a été prononcé on va
avoir toutes les séquences tu vas réagir
avec nous cette année vous avez eu la
chance d'avoir une star internationale
en président du jury une star qui a fait
une entrée fracassante une star que
j'adore je l'aime très fort c'est
Francis Huster j'adore Francis voilà et
regardez Francis il a fait un démarrage
voilà c'est français installation
[Applaudissements]
qui va parfaitement ces bombes dans
Casino Royal
[Applaudissements]
alors un des moments forts de la soirée
a eu à 21h30 c'est notre Jean-Pierre
Foucault qu'on aime on adore il va
rester Jean-Pierre pour l'instant ah oui
c'est le taulier on va l'enlever
il le sait et franchement elle fait
l'amour en direct
les animateurs on va être très franc
quasiment plus fort mais à tenir des
directeurs vous vous le faites Nikos le
fait encore c'est un exemple très
difficile et je suis en confiance avec
lui je l'adore où est-ce que je l'aime
moi je l'embrasse fort mon Jean-Pierre
Foucault qui a été encore formidable
franchement c'est le taulier c'est vrai
que c'est un bonheur de le revoir mais
je pense que c'est que ça cartonne aussi
Miss France parce que je pense que les
gens sont aussi contents de voir
Jean-Pierre Foucault voilà des seules
émissions encore qui présente et il le
dit c'est vraiment il tient et en plus
c'est bien de sortir on sort le taulier
le soir de Miss France alors regardez il
s'est chauffé et il s'est transformé en
Elton John regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce n'est pas moi mais c'est la saint
contestée de la pop alors faites comme
moi comme lui sortez les traces des
paillettes saucez vos grosses lunettes
monter le son quand 10 Miss Monde leur
cinéma sur le film Rocketman jump ouais
ça déménage
alors c'est pas lui bravo
vous étiez content de voir Jean-Pierre
Foucault toujours un bonheur pour l'ami
c'est elle sait qu'elle va voir
Jean-Pierre Foucault
tout le monde a rigolé ça c'est une
belle surprise il est fou alors pourquoi
vous avez voulu vous présenter un Miss
France comment est-ce que c'est des gens
qui vous disent ouais tu es magnifique
il faut que tu fasses Miss France parce
que moi je sais qu'ici voilà il y a pas
mal de gens qui encouragés
ou bien c'est vous qui vous êtes dit
franchement ou bien c'est vos parents
c'est qui c'est une longue histoire
alors c'est déjà par rapport à ma mère
parce que c'était présenté à l'élection
de Guadeloupe exactement 98 elle avait
été élu première de film et en fait elle
a gardé tous les souvenirs de son de son
élection elle est cassettes vidéo les
albums photos les chartes de première
dauphines et du coup quand j'étais
petite j'ai grandi en fait dans cet
univers parce que j'ai toujours voulu
faire comme elle et après à 13 ans le
président du Comité Miss Bastia qui est
le chef-lieu de la Guadeloupe m'a repéré
il a dit à ma mère dans 5 ans elle
revient donc après il a envoyé des
messages à ma mère il lui a dit bon
c'est quand qu'elle se présente il vous
a pas oublié
à quelqu'un dans 5 ans
[Rires]
mais donc ouais ils sont ils sont venus
le gars et du coup je me suis présenté à
l'élection Miss Basset et après du coup
comme la miss basta se présente à
l'élection de Miss Guadeloupe ça a été
une continuité
je pense que vous allez marquer
l'histoire des métiers franchement alors
j'oublie chez vous mais c'est un bonbon
c'est plus qu'un moment c'est une brique
à
[Rires]
l’œufs dans la famille sa mère était
magnifique il y a pas un frère
[Rires]
oui là Instagram il a une copie
[Applaudissements]
à son âge hein
c'est ce que c'est oui merci calme-toi
il va pas nicono cet été
en Italie
[Musique]
alors moi j'ai adoré le tableau que j'ai
préféré c'est le tableau Avengers
c'était très fort regardez c'était à
22h08 parce que j'ai tout noté
j'ai tout noté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me rappelle de la choristes
incroyable parce que vous partez avant
réviser toutes les choristes c'est ça ou
pas pendant un mois on révise on révise
les Coréens
et le jour même aussi on répète la
matinée
22h13 il y a votre portrait il arrive à
22h13 le portrait de Miss Guadeloupe on
l'attendait
vous avez regardé où bien sûr vous étiez
promise Guadeloupe oui j'avais dit ici
qu'elle allait gagner
pourtant les femmes peuvent se tromper
sur lui ou ton lui se trompe jamais sur
les femmes non CC ouais non il a Élie et
moi j'avais dit c'est j'avais dit comme
j'avais oublié Miss Réunion j'en avais
fait ma favorite oui peut-être oui
juste avant les discours de un moment
hyper redouté comme pour chaque Miss la
chute c'est Miss Roussillon le skin
carafontaine la fille de Laurent qui m'a
fait des frais regardez
elles sont 30 elles viennent de toutes
les régions de France et salut belle
deviendra Miss France
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au téléphone elle va bien voilà tout va
bien alors 23h15 c'est l'heure que
j'attendais moi j'adore c'est l'heure
des fameux discours alors comme vous
l'avez travaillé vous le discours mon
discours je l'avais préparé ça faisait
déjà un mois ou pas alors ma mère a vu
le discours mais c'est vrai que c'était
avec des coachs plutôt que voilà
il faut rester naturel parce qu'après il
y a un côté récité et ce qui est
important aussi c'est plus naturel et
toi tu as été là naturel oui j'avoue
c'est naturel tu as été très mal mais il
faut faire attention à ça regardez
regardez le discours de 1000 Guadeloupe
je m'appelle Indira en Piot j'ai certes
18 ans mais ce soir je veux prouver
qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour réaliser ses
rêves et que tout est possible
faire de moi votre nouvelle Miss France
me permettra de continuer d'incarner
encore plus puissamment ces nouvelles
générations maîtrisant les réseaux
sociaux et les nouvelles technologies
j'aimerais poursuivre mon engagement et
mon soutien envers les personnes
atteintes de cancer notamment en hommage
à ma grand-mère qui nous a
malheureusement quitté cette année
[Applaudissements]
enfin rappelons que nous sommes dans un
weekend gagnant alors pourquoi ne pas
ramener la coupe et la couronne à la
maison allez les bleus
[Applaudissements]
quand on vous pose des questions après
le discours sur l'actualité c'est
préparer ou c'est l'improvisation non ça
dépend face après faut toujours être
informé l'actualité donc alors vraiment
les questions pour le coup parce que je
participe à la sélection c'est Cindy ça
qui les a choisi
et on choisit dans des grandes
thématiques qui ont marqué l'actualité
et c'est envoyé par le service
interactif de TF1 lui-même qui n'est
sélectionne sur Internet c'est chaud
23h15 donc c'était l'heure
c'est l'heure des fameux discours et il
faut avouer c'est hyper stressant de
parler devant des millions de personnes
non mais c'est vrai regardez vous ici
voilà vous y arrivez une fois sur deux
et pour le fond lutter contre le
changement climatique éradiquer la fin
dans le monde c'est le discours des Miss
chaque année c'est ce qu'on appelle ce
qu'on a appelé l'instant Valérie benaima
la vie est courte et longue à la fois et
je m'investis aujourd'hui auprès de la
prévention routière afin de sensibiliser
les jeunes aux dangers de la route mais
dans la vie je ne recule devant rien et
d'ailleurs mes proches et ma famille
m'appelle Wonder Woman et je vous fais
une promesse aussi c'est que cette
fossette qui sert de soleil sera
toujours auprès de vous je n'ai pas
toujours été à l'aise dans mes baskets
alors je suis plus à l'aise dans mes
talons ce soir je pense que la vie elle
est belle je pense que c'est une
aventure je vais terminer par une petite
confidence j'aime les gens et j'aime la
vie cet instant vous a été offert par
Valérie bénaïque alors voilà
le discours alors justement
Indira vous le truc là de ramener la
couronne et la coupe à la maison c'est
vous l'avez trouvé dernier moment où ça
c'était quand vous l'avez trouvé vous
avez dû vous dire là c'est plus l'aide
un peu dans mon entourage de mon comité
ils m'ont dit il faut parler de
l'actualité donc c'était les Bleus
aussi qui m'a aidé
elle est meilleure pour aider les gens
je rigole
alors il est génial ça fait déjà que je
travaille avec elle tous ceux qui ont
fait ça son virus
je vais vous dire 2023 j'ai plus aucun
filtre alors déjà que 2002 c'était chaud
à 2023 je vous dis moi j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] calme-toi bébé l'autre question
j'ai trouvé très naturel quand vous
parlez bravo mais pourquoi est-ce que
systématiquement tous les discours de
Miss et ça vous sert pas sont justement
un peu niaiseux ou du coup on a
l'impression que vous êtes non mais on a
l'impression que vous êtes un peu bébête
parce que j'aurais un peu niaiseux
parler du cancer de l'humanité la guerre
dans le monde machin pourquoi vous avez
18 ans pas être plus naturel parler des
choses de votre âge on sait très bien
que le cancer c'est grave mais enfin
c'est pas votre assez c'est pas ma
grand-mère en fait
tout simplement pas enfin en hommage à
ma grand-mère parce que ma grand-mère
elle a été atteinte en toute de cinq
cancers c'était une période difficile
l'année a commencé
c'est assez compliqué la bouffe parce
que les parties en janvier et c'était
une femme c'était le pilier de la
famille c'est mon c'est un exemple
c'était vraiment comme une deuxième mère
et du coup j'ai voulu lui rendre hommage
moi la maladie du cancer c'est vrai
qu'on l'a vécu avec la famille et
justement
cette année j'ai choisi d'être marraine
des Amazones Guadeloupe donc c'est une
association qui aide les femmes
atteintes de cancer et je me suis dit en
hommage à ma grand-mère je peux déjà
faire ça et pourquoi pas faire plus de
choses
je voulais pas donner de la pitié ou
quoi que ce soit c'était vraiment parler
de ma grand-mère parce que elle a
toujours été à mes côtés donc brave
c'est tout ce que
ta gueule
on va revenir on va revenir sur un des
moments que j'attendais c'était 23h le
défilé en maillot et comme j'adore
la mer j'adore la plage
j'adore la mode donc forcément ça
m'intéressait regardez il aura fallu
attendre 23h35 pour les voir des films
en deux pièces
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait j'ai pas du tout stressé le soir
du prime pas du tout vraiment pas du
tout quoi tout a glissé comme ça direct
je vais pas refaire le problème de Miss
France bien sûr donc on profite
pleinement
voilà c'est un défilé quand tu as un peu
plus c'est plus compliqué non mais bon
la mer
[Musique]
on n'a pas les mêmes dans la tête
[Rires]
tu vas
[Applaudissements]
elle a raison alors c'est la minuit 48
ah ouais casino 1h du matin j'avais la
gueule en billet
mais normal c'est un beau spectacle et
je le dis c'est pas parce que tu fais
plus long que tu es payé plus cher par
la chaîne au contraire voilà c'est
vraiment donc voilà donc si ils en ont
eu pour leur argent ils ont fait le
premier reproduction deuxième partie de
soirée qui produit ça c'est excellent
bravo
sans rigoler je charrie pas j'ai kiffé
j'ai trouvé que les tableaux Avengers
tout ça et tout très fort j'ai kiffé
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment magnifique et
on a l'image de ton sacre de votre sacre
il dira et c'est vrai que à chaque fois
moi je vous dis un truc vous allez
revoir c'est quand même cruel parce
qu'en fait tout le monde se jette sur
celle qui est Miss France et la pire
place ses premières de faire tu es toute
seule tu es fière à tout le monde toi tu
es comme ça tu vois la meuf tout le
monde lui tombe dessus il lui met une
couronne et toi frère tu appelles ton
uber non mais sérieux
non mais ça aurait pu être Castaldi quoi
c'est un truc de fou c'est c'est fou
c'est fou physiquement première dauphine
qu'est-ce qu'elle dit alors il est très
beau c'est vrai et si il a plus qu'à se
faire réduire un petit peu la poitrine
il peut faire bah si on verra elle est
magnifique
deux candidates l'une d'entre elles dans
un instant
par la voix de Francis Huster deviendra
Miss France 2023
[Musique]
monsieur le Président
je vous remets l'enveloppe dans laquelle
se trouve le nom de Miss France 2023 je
vous en prie
[Musique]
Miss France 2023 est et restera mais
squadou
ouais bien aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
première docile donc je le répète plus
dans Pas de Calais
Guadeloupe et Miss France 2023
il y a plein de gens que vous regardez
le concours parce que ça fait plus de 7
millions de spectateurs qu'est-ce que
vous disiez parce que la tenté est
interminable je vous disiez avec l'autre
on se disait que c'était long vraiment
[Rires]
je me perds dans tes yeux parce qu'elle
a des yeux bleus mais c'était pour
détendre l'atmosphère qu'est-ce qu'on
s'est dit encore qu'on dans tous les cas
on avait gagné on avait qu'une belle
aventure on s'est bien passé
en fait vous avez pour moi le plus
important c'était de rester assuré parce
que comme je l'ai dit on le vit qu'une
seule fois Miss France
alors la question on va vous poser
toutes les questions qu'on pose à Miss
France forcément
non attendez attendez
la dernière question ça sera la dernière
question terminera par ça merci voilà
c'est une amie
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
disent que concombre Miss France est
sexiste je dis que c'est pas sexiste
pourquoi parce que en fait chaque femme
s'assume si toutes les femmes se sont
prises c'est qu'elles ont quelque chose
à défendre et être féministe et tout
simplement défendre des valeurs et
défendre des idées donc
est-ce qu'on peut être féministe et
faire Miss France vous avez à peu près
répondu
c'est des fentes des idées défendre des
valeurs c'est mettre en avant ce qu'on
veut dire en fait et c'est tout
simplement défendre l'égalité de femmes
aussi qu'est-ce que tu dis aux gens qui
disent que le défilé en maillot de bain
c'est pas bien moi c'est bien moi j'ai
adoré des filets en maillot de bain
genre les défilé tout simplement
ou moi j'adorais c'était top enfin on a
de la musique on fait des chorégraphies
on est deux on est sous l'effet des
projecteurs enfin c'est incroyable en
combinaison de ski c'est quand même
moins
peut-être pour le prochain prime
est-ce que le concours devrait trouver
aux personnes transexuel
maire de famille maintenant après c'est
vrai que c'est c'est assez compliqué
parce que c'est c'est un tremplin à Miss
France et c'est tous les jours mais
après vous savez si il y a une bonne
organisation tout se passe bien
justement là il se passe quoi là quand
vous êtes élu Miss France juste après il
se passe quand on vous met une couronne
et on vous met dans une voiture et on
vous emmène
toutes les mises la famille
[Musique]
elle la prend il y a une conférence de
presse moi j'ai découvert ça aussi il y
a une conférence de presse et après il y
a pour la première fois depuis deux ans
qui avait le covid il y a une fête vous
avez bien dansé à prendre la mets dans
une voiture et alors il y a Guillaume
aujourd'hui
Guillaume parce qu'il conduit pas
[Applaudissements]
qui est formidable d'ailleurs Diane à la
radio qui a été très drôle en plus lors
de la est-ce que vous avez envie de
faire après des de la radio de la télé
ou pas du tout mais après ça dépend je
me dis que
si toutefois
en tout cas j'aime bien aussi la radio
donc c'est ça la radio la télé ça vous
ça vous dit ou pas
la radio j'ai enfin une comédienne moi
quand j'étais petite je faisais beaucoup
de théâtre donc ah j'adore Alexia est-ce
que tu crois
ah oui vraiment oui et je trouve ça très
bien ça est très différente de Diane
c'est vrai que Diane elle a un
tempérament de feu c'est plus
âgé que toi puisqu'elle a été couronnée
elle avait 24 ans donc voilà je trouve
ça ce qui est incroyable c'est la
diversité des Miss et non on a on a fait
une fête alors pour le coussin
journaliste sans photographe que avec
toutes les Miss France on s'est bien
amusés quand on voit tous les parcours
être cher parce que voilà s'il y a des
vrais carrières derrière et Alexia
génial je trouve qu'on se voit passer
souvent
on va se voir plus cette année en 2023
c'est ma résolution je vais voir c'est
beaucoup plus de temps avec toi Alexia
alors la question bien sûr tout le monde
se pose il dira tu as 18 ans
tu es mise Guadeloupe 2022 Miss France
2023 la question que tout le monde se
pose je vais te demander de prendre un
petit peu de temps pour répondre il est
21h17 nous sommes en direct dans un
instant il y aura la première de
Magellan ah oui sur C8 Alexia merci tu
es un amour on t'aime mais tu es très
belle j'habite aussi belle 2023 je te
dis c'est ton année
il me dira oui
et tu
en couple
il sait tout simplement mon coeur
appartient tous les Français
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
est-ce que vous êtes en couple ou pas
parce que c'est ce que disent toutes les
Miss France on leur dit de dire ça on
leur dit de dire mais mon cœur
appartient à tous les Français alors
même pas bah c'est ce que disait il y a
de l'air aussi oui
voilà on ne dit pas de le dire mais j'ai
envie de le dire mais je suis en couple
vous n'êtes pas encore
disponible pas disponible
c'est moi-même posé la question